season three Emily in Paris we are here
in Paris and you did not come to play
with this fashion no I did not you were
strategically covered in all the right
places can you tell me a secret about
this dress
uh a secret about this dress is I had to
have about three people get me into it
you have to move breasts and yeah that
was the funnest part but it's Stefan
Roland and this is the designer that's
featured in season three of Emily and
Bali and he is incredible I actually
have worn them before what I presented
at the Emmys several years ago so I was
happy to be reunited with him and I'm
wearing his shoes I'm wearing Bulgari
which is you know never a bad thing so
yeah absolutely stunning thank you and
you've been such a wonderful addition to
this show just the the chaotic moments
that your character shares with Lily
Collins character how does the drama
this season compare to Seasons past
everything's bigger this season and
bigger in terms of uh more gorgeous
locations more fashion of course but
also they go all the show goes all
through the country this this year so
you get to see all places in Paris
outside of Paris but also the story
lines the characters not just bear but
they're more there's more depth I think
and more expansion and so everybody has
really deep character and relationships
and it's it's really fun and comedy
there's a lot of funny the first three
episodes it's just it's you could feel
the joy of the writers writing it it was
really really fun and special
my entire life I've been practical I
make one romantic decision and it bit me
in the ass are you talking about work or
Gabrielle Paris oh I can't wait to see
what you guys cooked up I do have to
tell you when you were just talking
about your Bulgari Jewels I noticed this
very stunning New Edition yeah
congratulations thank you very much how
is wedding planning going uh we're we're
planning and then not planning we keep
going oh let's just enjoy being engaged
it's so hectic so we've been just so
busy with work and planning trips and
you know holiday travel so we're gonna
get it done yeah I mean if you're on a
show called Emily in Paris we're in
Paris here honestly it's the most
romantic city in the world I mean we
have to go we just are obsessed with the
architecture here and we want it to be
somewhere beautiful so maybe who knows a
little a little fashion inspo maybe from
from your character like are you
thinking wedding dresses at all yes I'm
all yeah that's a fun bet it is fun you
know you know it's fun to fantasize and
start looking at designers I mean that's
just fun it is and you're like
definitely a costume change for now it's
like you don't it's like a given you get
married there's like three three yeah
exactly so I know I gotta let you go my
final question we love you on Emily in
Paris but you know we're so excited to
see you back on Grace thank you how was
Addison going to shake things up in the
coming in the coming season we're doing
a really strong Women's Health storyline
um And Addison's out on the front lines
uh with
um Bailey and it's really incredible I'm
really proud of the work I'm going back
on Thursday to shoot another episode and
then I do another one after the holidays
and we have some really special guests
coming in and it's going to be it's
really cool I'm very proud of the
writing and the work so Gray's Emily and
a wedding yeah
busy woman yes I am I'm so happy to see
you thank you
[Music]